you're one of the the show's original
cast members but left after the first
season
um what was the decision process like
for you to decide to come back
you know i feel like i'm in a different
place in my life now i feel like my kids
are older
i asked my kids if they wanted to do it
and they were super excited to do it and
you know i was super excited to be back
and miami is so amazing it's you know
fashion it's it's just so sexy we have
art like it's just so much fun to be
there and be with my friends
was there any hesitation like was there
one or two things where you're like
yeah but this
um i just feel like i'm sure being on
reality tv is probably not good for your
dating life i don't think it is but
i i just was like i'll just do it
well the treasure the trailer is
absolutely crazy there's partying
there's fighting there's kissing they're
screaming there's tons of drama between
you and the ladies
what can you tease
for this season for us
i mean i feel like you know the women
there's we're so diverse i feel like our
cast is super diverse i feel like
you know we've all evolved like the
original ogs we've all evolved so much
and we're in different places in our
lives so i definitely feel like this
year is going to be really really
interesting i feel like there's
definitely drama there's a lot of drama
in the show
and i feel like there are moments where
you think this huge event's gonna happen
and then i don't know if it's gonna
happen every day was like are we filming
are we not so yeah just
a lot of that kind of stuff
definitely well you know in the trailer
you said it is your game now so what
part of your life are you most excited
to share with the world
i feel like my independence you know i
was a housewife when i was on season one
i basically focused on scotty and my
children now that my kids are older i'm
able to focus on the charities that i
want to help
i'm able to focus on my businesses and
the things that i'm most passionate
about
amazing well there are a couple new
ladies in the lineup on the show
lots of different personalities who do
you have the hardest time
um getting along with or relating to out
of the ladies and then the opposite who
do you get along with the most
i feel like i get along the best um with
maybe lisa hodgstein and alexia
um
we get along we hang out we were hanging
out before
i started retaping the show
um and i feel like the person i like to
spend the least amount of time with um
is probably adriana
okay you know it's a lot of hot and cold
and i'm i'm not that type of friend
yeah there's a lot of like there's
always history with these shows right
there's things that have happened
lots of situations for you going in was
it let's let's do a brand new clean
slate or is it hard to let go of some of
the things that that have happened in
the past
no i feel like i'm you know i feel like
i'm not like that i feel like when i
start something i have to have a
conversation and have to start over you
know marisol and i really didn't get
along the first season i did the show
and so we spoke um
and had this whole conversation and she
was like you know i always liked you and
i'm like you know i always liked you too
it was just misunderstanding
miscommunication or whatnot so i
definitely wanted to go back into the
season optimistic
you know open and wanted to work on my
relationships with all the girls
yeah in the trailer uh your only fan's
account seems to be a really hot topic
um why was this such a a a big source of
drama do you think for everyone
um i feel like most of the girls don't
really keep up with social platforms you
know i feel like miami is very small and
and
their bubble is probably kind of smaller
than mine
and so they um they didn't know enough
about the platform because if you look
at the platform there's artists on there
there's chefs there's trainers there's
you know it's it's a variety it's
basically for people that are your fans
you know they're your true fans not just
someone that follows you but if you
follow me on only fans and you subscribe
to me even though my platform is free
then i know you really want to know more
about me i know you want you know
exclusive content and that shows me so
then i feel more apt to reply to your
dms than just anybody on instagram
right
um the first ever real housewives
ultimate girls trip kicked off this year
um if you could pick any housewife from
the franchise to go on an ultimate girls
trip who would you pick and where would
you go
um i would probably pick um cynthia
bailey because i'm obsessed with her
she's so cute um and i would say we
should do
like a safari together i feel like a
safari like to africa would be super oh
that would be good all right
now
listen
in the trailer the women made a
comparison to you and kim kardashian so
my question is this
many of us would like to see the two of
you reconcile do you think that's
something that's possible um and and how
did you feel about that comparison
i mean i feel like anybody can say
anything sometimes when you're on a
reality tv show you know kim and i speak
we're on great terms you know i feel
like the media made more of our
situation than it really was and it
probably had more trouble than it you
know it made it added fuel to the fire
so um yeah i don't know why adriana even
brought that up because honestly like
we're in a great place you know
there's no love lost i love them and
oh okay
yeah you're right i think that out there
there is this misconception that
you're not talking and that it is not
that way but but that's not the case
yeah no
okay amazing well thank you and thank
you so excited to see the season thank
you